and it's all improv does it be magic to
us to like we don't practice anything we
get on stage and we go
you know I mean we got my man Craig
right here I'm gonna attest to that we
never sit around and have no meetings
about I Pro we in this city so this what
we go none of that because it's so
genuine and like I said that energy that
I was talking about it's so strong and
it's so genuine that when we get on
stage it's literally magic
[Music]
[Music]
so let me just I'll just welcome you to
the show and then we'll kick it off all
right no you're good and that's for you
as well that's hot breath water
exclusive breath breath water yeah it's
got the he's got the logo on there for
you it's all for you man so here we go
hop read the verse welcome back to
another hopper episode I'm your host
comedian Joel Byers
this is hot breath your weekly guide to
comedy mastery and today's guest hot
brethren and sistren not only a master
of improv not only a master of stand-up
comedy but also a master of mindset this
is a cat lost his dad at two years old
grew up in DC and what they called the
shadows of the US Capitol since been
able to create his own success through a
solid foundation with family but also
through a solid foundation of mindset
went to college graduated jumped right
into comedy and now we see him as a
comedy superstar but he didn't just roll
over one day and become that this cat
actually lost his job then the next week
actually books wild and out but not
after having to fly to a wild down
audition after selling his clothes at
Plato's Closet to be able to buy the
flight to get there so this is going to
be an example of if you put your mind to
it you can achieve it but it's also
putting in the work so he has since
Wilding out of course since 85 south
show and now hot breath podcasts listen
man let me just say whoever your
research person is is amazing alright
that's how you end up give me all water
yeah yeah yeah good research people I
mean I need to get more white people
working right now exactly your white
person so that's what I'm saying giving
you your props push it my pre-show I
like what you're doing yeah yeah we've
had we've had Carlos Miller on here a
couple times have clayton english on
here we've had chad we've had 85 squat
out here that's what it is
now we got you got me that's what it is
man I'm happy to be here with you so I
would really like to dive into your your
mentality behind what you do cuz in
researching you you are one of the
funniest people
live but then when you hear you in
interviews you're always spitting wisdom
you're all you have you know brother
knowledge if you were yes that's just
that you know oh everything that I do is
kind of not even kind of is a reflection
of who I am as a person how I grew up
like you have a lot of people who you
know take negative experiences and and
they let it affect them you know and
detrimental II like not choose not to
everything that I've been through is you
know just a reflection of Who I am and
what makes me unique as a person so you
know like brother knowledge is just
something that came from my head you
know I grew up around my uncles so I had
two uncles that were actually in the
Nation of Islam so just that influence
and seeing those guys as a young man and
how serious they were about the things
that they say and it's funny as the
videos are it's always a real message
within them and um you know most of the
knowledge that I received from them
always came that way because me being a
young man they knew they couldn't give
it to me in a manner in which I wouldn't
be able to comprehend it so they were
able to give me you know understanding
through a level of me being able to
comprehend the message that they had so
you know it's just me kind of paying
homage to one of those things that you
know helped make me the person that I am
when it comes to me being me you know me
and people are striving and me
personally as well you know I'm not
aiming for the middle with my stand-up
or this podcast or anything so someone
and you're by no means at like the peak
at all and we know that was just getting
started and that's what's amazing is you
haven't even really been in the game
that long and in terms of this being a
lifelong journey right so what do you
attribute to like such a quick rise like
is it the mindset is that the secret
sauce and I don't even really think it
was a quick rise to be honest with you
because in this game a lot of people
believe that your journey starts when
they start caring about it and that it
really doesn't work like that your
journey starts when it starts once
people start to pay attention to it then
that's when they kind of give you the
credit for kind of starting the race and
that's respectable because that's the
way things go but for me my journey
started when I got on stage for the
first time at the open mic night in
Greensboro North Carolina at the comedy
zone so from that point until me sitting
here with you right now is all a
reflection of the journey that I've been
and continue to walk so you know I did
my first four minutes in 2008 so I've
been going ever since 2008 I just put a
post up yesterday that uh you know said
that you're just talking about my car
used to break down I had a Saturn V
there at 332 thousand miles on it
I took it to trade it in and the guy
from the dealership came out and was
like look man you ain't got nobody you
can bless with this man we're gonna baby
get you nothin forward so so those are
the things that people don't see you
know me having to walk home from the
repair shop two miles cuz my car broke
down and the pair of hard bottoms cuz I
was leaving my line brothers win and it
made me have a different respect for
Martin Luther King and him I'm like if
they did this daily I respect them from
being able to walk into a shoes like
this is not the test that I would want
to take on every day for freedom so
those little things that you learn over
time you know the things that make you
appreciate the journey that you own
because for me I realize now that the
point that I'm at now in my walk what
keeps me humble and understanding that
the work that I do is that all the
things that would be considered to be
nuisances or problems in my life now six
seven years ago would have fixed
everything that I had going on they
would have been the solutions all I got
a I had to pay $3,000 in flights for the
next month seven years ago $3,000 would
have changed my whole situation right
you know so it keeps me understanding
that importance of being able to
recognize you know you have an
obligation to yourself first and
foremost to make sure that you have
peace of mind and then you also have an
obligation to your craft to make sure
that you never take anything for granted
because you know I respect people's
journey who go up the elevator I mean
it's cool you know I mean I however you
get there I'm not concerned with anybody
else's journey but my own but I respect
the fact that I walk up the steps and
I'm continuing to walk up the steps
because and I would you know I much
rather not saying there's anything wrong
whatever works for you is for you but I
must rather go up the steps then go up
the elevator I have to walk down the
steps because when you got to walk down
the steps then it's a whole side and
process of this game
that you don't know about but when
you're coming up you meet all the people
the steps in you learn how to navigate
your way through you know the trips and
falls and you know you see all of those
different things on your way up you know
in the hands that you shake on the way
up these are people who take the same
journey as you take so you build
relationships with people that always be
able to utilize what you do and vice
versa
so you know it's just the way it works
all right you know I haven't been in the
game for a long time in comparison to
what they say it takes to really become
a superstar we baby in the game yeah as
far as my journey I really started
walking up the steps the whole way so
you know where I am on the steps might
not be where somebody may believe I
should be you're somebody might not
think that is you know you as successful
as you could be but luckily for me I
don't base with anybody else thinks on
what it is that I do and that's what I
admire about your your approach to it as
well as cuz I I say it was quick because
I've been in the game nine years alright
so I start 2010 so it's like thinking
well in nine years it's like if someone
like Chico was already like here even
it's it's it's easy in this game to
start comparing yourself to other yeah
you shouldn't you shouldn't compare
yourself to anyone else because nobody
journey is yours but yours and it can
become difficult not to because you know
you you're basing your success off of
what you believe success to be in the
industry that you're in and um you know
I I can respect people who don't know
how to navigate out of that but for me
and like I said my background is really
really different I've never been the
same as anybody else you know so I've
always had to learn how to operate
within the space that was unique I said
my father was killed when I was two most
of the males in my family were involved
in some type of illegal illicit activity
you know my mother didn't graduate from
high school you know I mean like all of
these things made me a unique person and
I always had to embrace the fact that I
was unique like when sometimes my
friends would be outside playing
football and basketball in the street I
would have to walk to the Safeway the
grocery store with a cart and get all
the groceries for the house and walk
pass all my friends playing outside
which I had to learn how to embrace
because I didn't have a choice so you
have a choice in life when you have to
do things that you can't control like we
all have responsibilities that you
have any option as to whether or not you
have to complete gotta pay your bills
you gotta drink water you gotta bust
nuts [ __ ] like that you know I mean so
it's like those are the things that you
have no control over anything that you
have no control over them in my opinion
the best way that you can embrace those
things is to take the things that you do
have control over and make them and
cater them to you in the best way
possible so you don't have to worry
about the stress of those things causing
you to be negligent in the things that
you can't control
soon that was something that I was able
to do and had to figure out very early
in my life like it wasn't something that
I had a choice in so me having to figure
those things out young kind of prepared
me for what it is that I'm doing now you
know we live in a time where you can
give your pump opinion publicly and
privately at the same time you can tell
me how unfunny and ain't [ __ ] I am
without me even knowing what your face
looks like so me having to go through
life and learn the things that I learned
as a young man prepared me for the
industry that I'm in now because I'm not
affected the same way that other people
are affected by those things because
I've had to do it when nobody knew me
but the people who knew me and I still
had to engage and you know life amongst
those people and still be cool with
having a you know complete tasks that
were given to me by somebody who I
didn't have a choice as to whether or
not I was gonna do it or not
so that's where the mature mindset yeah
yeah definitely definitely definitely
because you know I I see people all the
time who you know allow things that
happen to them to be used as an excuse
to not you know do whatever it is that
they're - yeah oh man this happened to
me and I'm from this place and I did
none of that matters you know I mean and
that's just my personal opinion but
don't none of that matter cares about
your plight only you care about your
plight and only you I ever be able to
care about it in the capacity that you
you know ever gonna be able to make any
real change about it so for me I
understand that there's no way for me to
be able to be successful if I'm not
basing the success off of what I
believed successes
that would the society believe success
is or what the person next to me
believed success is I have to establish
my own success so therefore I can relish
in the things that mean something to me
and that'll carry you throughout the
cloud of you know comparing yourself to
people or not getting that opportunity
or getting told no and all of that all
of that oh you know it doesn't matter
because once you establish your
successes it doesn't matter if anybody
else looks at your success and says it's
not we're supposed to be so is that
something you'd recommend comics do
starting out is establish what successes
yes yes definitely establish what you
want and don't make it vague all I want
to be the next Kevin Hart I want to be
the next bill burr I want to be tan
there's already a Kevin Hart and Bill
burr so how are you going to do what you
need to do to become the first you you
know I mean and it doesn't have to look
the way that people say it looks you
know I live in North Carolina to this
day I went to college in winston-salem
North Carolina and I still lived there
when I graduated college I didn't want
to go back to DC because I knew once I
established that I was going to do this
for a living once you start to hit those
pitfalls it's a little different when
people that know you are inquiring about
you you know well being you know if a
stranger says all you ain't [ __ ] you
shouldn't be doing this okay but when
your mom is like baby what's going on
you know it's not coming from a place of
malice she's really concerned about your
well-being so therefore you have to make
sure that well at least I had to make
sure that I didn't allow that to affect
me because I didn't know how it would
because I never dealt with that before
but I have dealt with you know my mom
influence on me and I know they're not
just using her as an example just
because that's probably the biggest
opinion that I accept in my life as far
as somebody who knows me I've never felt
or experienced what it felt like to have
her see me fail in a manner where there
was nothing to fall back on but my own
merit if I failed at school it was you
know a curriculum that wasn't being
followed if I failed at sports it was a
curriculum that wasn't being followed
when it comes to making your dreams come
true there is no curriculum
there's no blueprint so you have to
create it I'm creating a blueprint for
me and my family name you know so I I
didn't know how I would deal with my mom
seeing me you know catch them Ales that
you catch doing this as a you know
career and looking and like you know
baby you don't have to go through this
you good enough to do anything do
something else so I stayed why I didn't
know anybody I had to make it work and
it's you know North Carolina is not a
hotbed of talent nobody's really coming
there to look for talent it's plenty of
talent there just like it's plenty
attended everywhere but it doesn't have
the name of a New York or LA Atlanta so
if you can make a name for yourself in
that space then you're doing something
so that's the way I challenge myself and
I still live there now because it
provides a level of peace of mind to me
that I can't find anywhere else and I'm
totally fine with that being the case
when you establish your success do you
like do you have it written down
somewhere or here's the vision
I mean I'd started out writing five
point plans for myself this is just
something I learned from just coming
from the community that I came from and
it guys they influenced me growing up I
would 5 years 5 points and I can't move
from one or two until I complete one you
know I mean so I started in oh wait and
supposing I get myself five years to
complete these things and now I'm on
what you know I've been doing this
coming up on 11 years in August and I
morning but my fourth five-year plan cuz
I've accomplished the things that I
wanted to accomplish well that many
times already so it's like I challenge
myself every day you know every single
day that I wake up I challenge myself to
become a better version of me I want to
be the best version of Chico being that
I can be on a day to day basis and the
way that I do that is by developing a
program that's based on Who I am
first figuring out what that means
figure out who you are as a person
embrace it
whatever it may be you might get
scrutinized or criticized but as long as
you're not hurting yourself or hurting
anyone whatever it is you do is cool so
once you figure out what those things
are embrace that then it
easier for you to find the level of
success for you because you're basing it
off of you and you took that journey of
figuring out who you are as a person I
think a lot of the reason why comedians
get lost in the sauce when they come to
this game is because they're basing
their self-worth off what they believe
other people based self-worth off but it
shouldn't work like that
if it's if something's not for you it's
not for you but if you're chasing it
even if you accomplish what it is you're
chasing once you accomplish it it's
gonna really [ __ ] you up
cuz when you get there you're gonna
realize I did all this work for some
[ __ ] that doesn't even satisfy me in any
capacity so now you you know lost
because you feel like I've gotten there
I'm successful now cuz I got you know
show or whatever I'm doing in some
headline and I'm making money but you
don't have any inner peace you don't
have any type of knowledge of who you
are so now that you've accomplished this
goal whatever your goals may be if
you're not basing it off who you are
when you get to that point you won't
realize I don't waste it however many
years of my life chasing a goal that
wasn't even my goal to accomplish you
know I mean it seems environment is very
important and surrounding yourself with
people I've done over a hundred and
seventy of these episodes and it seems a
common theme with successful people is
they surround themselves with like
people in that higher-self mindset yeah
but that I've been blessed in regard to
that as well because when I came in the
game as far as when people start caring
and I'll say that's when we got on wild
and out okay and lows came in at the
same time and you know Llosa's old I've
been in the game longer and has been a
mentor in a lot of ways but we mentor
each other in a lot of ways just in life
but to come from nothing with a person
I'm talking about walking up and down
the street going the Western Union to
send fifty dollars home and washing your
clothes in the basement of the hotel to
being able to do what we're able to do
now at this point it's just a reflection
of it doesn't matter what points you're
at in regards to the people you surround
yourself with answer your question as
long as you surround yourself with
somebody else who has the same mentality
in regards to who they are
hmmm I love Who I am those are the
people I want to be around I don't care
what you do but if you you and you
embrace who you truly are and you stand
on it like a that's what I like this
what I don't like take it or leave it
those are the people that I want to be
around because I can learn something
about life that I can't learn live in my
own coz I'm living mine in the same way
you are so when we come together with
teaching each other about the world
based on reality and that's how you
build that energy that ends up
attracting the type of success that you
want in your life and to finding
yourself sounds it man it sounds like oh
I just find myself like right down is a
journey like where I came from yeah it's
a journey it's a journey like I've been
through a lot of things in my life you
know a whole lot of things that most
people wouldn't be able to handle you
know I've seen those things that you see
in movies and stories I've really
witnessed and lived through those type
of things so life is different for me
one of the first things I had to learn
how to deal with in life is death
because my father got kid when I was 2
years old so once I came into
understanding of who I was that's the
first thing that I had to recognize and
acknowledge that the person that is
supposed to be here is not here and
never will be
so learning to accept that alone makes
you find something within yourself
that's different but throughout life
I've dealt with that many many times
over you know my uncle Reggie was killed
in OH - cousin Dirk I can you know only
want to get into the long list of names
and situations but all of those things
have made me look at life differently
than most people look at life I don't
view life the same way as everybody else
I understand how it works from a
different perspective I know what it
feels like to have somebody say I'm
gonna see you later and you never see
him again you know I mean so I'm always
looking to figure out who and what I am
on a day to day basis because I went to
my father's grave site for the first
time when I was 21 years old he was
buried in the older part of the
graveyard lady took me back over to
where he was buried at and pointed at
the grass and said he in this area
somewhere
I'm like damn I don't even know if I'm
be talking to the right [ __ ] and
I mean like and that was just the
natural thought of what I had most
people would have been devastated but me
going through life having to figure that
out so early it was something that I
accepted and had to figure out at that
moment of how I was going to embrace
this being a reality going forward and
the reality is whatever this man had
done in his life up into that point when
someone took it hadn't been enough to
gone to himself a marker to let the
world know that he was here so my job in
this being my reality is to do my best
to not have this be my reality going
forward you know and those things made
me have to find out who I was a little
bit differently than everybody well a
lot of people are gonna say everybody
because I'm sure a lot of people have
journeys that are just as unique but
that was one of the things that made me
have to figure out who I was truly
because that's my reality I've never had
a basketball game or a fight or a show
or nothing that this person was present
for and when I went to go be present to
where the remains that he left him were
there was no way of me even finding out
where that was so at that point you have
a choice you can either sulk and feel
sorry for yourself and like woe is me or
you could say well I I have a
responsibility to make sure that
whatever I do here is going to not only
just leave a marker but leave a marker
that lasts way longer than once I they
put me in the grass or whatever they put
me at yeah and I have found that
long-term perspective of okay what will
this look like in five years or ten
years and that self-awareness that I'm
I'm being more mindful of trying to hone
in on self-awareness and conduct my
decisions based around who I am and
where I want to be so like personal
example for me and you may have one it's
like I got offered like a TV show where
I was paying us I was playing a slave
master and I was like yo in like five
years
I'm not gonna want to be like this was
my debut that I played like a slave
master you know so it's like having that
self-awareness and that long-term view
of like okay this may be a
bump now but it may be like a pothole
later like always having that long-term
view seems to be helpful well I think
it's our perspective and I really
believe that I believe the world is
based everything is based on perspective
because it's always another way of
looking at whatever it is that you got
going on because the energy that you put
out is what you're gonna receive let's
say you did play a slave master look at
the reality of it you would have
probably been a slave you would've been
a slave you know I mean yeah so it's
like the to be able to explain that to
people if you ever needed to what you
don't cause you don't have to explain
yourself to anybody but the people who
you allow to have influence in your life
so you have to that's another thing you
have to be very selective and strategic
on picking those people whose opinions
you allowed to affect your actions but
once you get that established then you
know that's the opportunity that you if
you did take it like hey this is the
reality of what the history is and I was
given this opportunity but there aren't
slaves anymore not a slave master I
could never be a slave master but I can
play one on TV you know I mean so it's
all about the way that you look and I
said it the way that you did it was
wrong because if that's the way you were
supposed to do it then you did what was
right for you
but it's all perspective because the
same way that you didn't take that role
whoever took it had the perspective of
you know what else I need this right now
me and some people might have just
needed it for the money or some people
might have needed it for the opportunity
some people just like I'm a challenge
myself I'm so against that to be able to
put myself in the position of being
something that I would never agree with
is you know a challenge for people who
entertain so I can understand all
perspectives but for me I just really
think that you know the energy that you
put out into the world is going to draw
back the results that you you know want
to see or don't want to see so as long
as your energy is right then you won't
be able to accomplish whatever it is you
set out to accomplish you know I mean
that's why I appreciate about your game
is you understand the art of the
independent hustle and creating your own
success and now with the internet and
everything comedians can do that more
than ever right it's like what are some
ways or tips you have for comics who
should
just build their own foundation well
it's easier now than it's ever been
because you know 20 years ago if this
was you know my reality I would be all
of us really especially the people on a
while and now just to use that as an
example would be a whole lot more famous
if the internet didn't exist hmm because
if the internet didn't exist the access
to us would be a whole lot less you know
than it is now so you think when the
Living Color was on like they were
superstars because the odds of you being
able to have contact or interact with
them or let them know how you feel about
him whether it be negative or positive
it was very difficult you had to write a
letter and then get a letter back and
then write another letter and then you
know I mean like it's different now now
you have direct access to anybody
beyonce is the biggest star in the world
but you can go on her Instagram page and
type of comment in her comments and the
odds of her seeing that are a whole lot
more than the odds of her saying the
letter 20 years ago in a 15,000 letters
a day so just utilize that aspect and
whatever it is you want to do I don't
care what it is if you want to be a
comedian if you just want to be an
Instagram entertainer start that's the
biggest thing most people just sit
around and don't start you can talk a
hole in your head but until you stop
putting forth the effort the universe
thing gonna give you nothing back
because you haven't given anything to
work off so you got to put forth some
type of effort just I tell people that
all the time
people come up and be like I want to be
a comic well have you done any standup I
don't care what you do especially
college students we do a lot of colleges
and they'd be like man I want to be a
comedian I'm like man you're in college
they have to utilize funds to let you do
what you want to do do it while it's
free cuz once you leave here nothing's
free anymore everything costs money so
the best thing you can do why you here
is utilize this place who is put here to
help advance you as a human being and do
it for nothing when it doesn't cost you
anything and you learn the game so when
you get out here and have to use your
money you
already built some type of foundation if
you have a skill set at it that's gonna
follow you and it makes it a little bit
easier for you to get out here and start
the press and push your envelope because
you've already started in a place where
it didn't cost you anything and with and
that pressure financial stability wasn't
on you you don't have that when you're a
college student and for those people who
aren't and just trying to do it on their
own you can go to Rite Aid and buy a
cell phone you know I mean and you can
go to Starbucks in your Wi-Fi so it's
really no excuse now for you not to be
able to put for some type of effort you
you can't cheat the game you have to put
in the work you have to get out here and
put your feet on the pavement and do
something and once you start doing
something then you'll start to see the
results of you doing something and you
got to be able to recognize what success
is because even if you you know go from
I remember the first Instagram posts I
put up got 12 likes I mean and I was
excited about the fact that I got 12
didn't show all the names and the number
you know I mean but that's the
difference that was the first 12 and I
was excited about that first 12 and I
embraced that first 12 to get to the
next which was 24 and then you know 36
and then on and on and on but the only
way that happened is putting the effort
forth and embracing the moment that you
are in like the walk is the walk you got
to embrace the ugly Carlos me and Carlos
say that all the time you got to embrace
the ugly like rest in peace and nipsey
hussle he had a quote a say sometimes
you just got to cut out all the fun cut
out all the [ __ ] get ugly and grind
mm-hmm
you know I mean that's the reality of
what you have to do those days when I
was how I got three hundred and thirty
two thousand miles on the Saturn Vue is
because I was out here in it moving
around every day doing something working
a regular job and doing this for no
money just to get myself in a situation
where my energy is starting to match
what I need to come back to me
because I'm putting forth the type of
effort that people are gonna see even if
you don't like what I do if you're
watching I'm gathering all of that and
it's helping propel me to the next step
and the only thing to get into the next
level and anything that you do it just
gives you a better view of what you
can't get to you know I mean it's like
if you can't see over the edge when you
finally get up over the edge then you
see everything that's over the edge so
the more you climb and grow
it never stops you know I mean in the
things that you chase you never stop
jay-z just became a billionaire but he's
still working Bill Gates and all these
different people and you know I don't
even everybody
that's successful they still work
because it's not about the money it's
about the view it's about what you get
to see because the money is just all
money to me in my opinion and I say this
all the time I hope everybody gets the
money so you can see that it doesn't do
anything but just makes the things that
you can't control easier to deal with
money is like like a moon bounce kind of
you know I mean like in life we fall
down and we ain't got no money when you
fall down you hitting a concrete
straight concrete scraping your knees
bust your head open you know I mean
bleeding gotta lick your wounds and get
up and you're limping to the next thing
but the more money you get now your moon
bounce starts to blow up so when you
fall now you don't hit the concrete it
just bounce back up mm-hmm
so that's all it does it just allows you
to be able to buy some [ __ ] that you
want and not have the things that you
can't control that life is gonna give
you cause you to just break down you
know I mean I remember when my car used
to break down that [ __ ] used to stress
me out because it's like damn now I got
to come up with $900 to get some ball
bearings when my rent is due
like what the [ __ ] am I gonna do that's
what money does de-stress it eliminates
that aspect but the more you get then
you're just going to a different bracket
of stress so all you're doing is just
blowing up your mattress and blowing up
your moon bounce rather so when you know
you you fall down and you bump your head
or some
comes is just a cushion but the real
success comes from the view it comes
from what you get to see from your work
like I didn't know that this part of the
world existed before I got to this point
and money can't buy you that like money
can't buy you the experiences that you
have when you really work towards your
goal like I've had people who I grew up
just idolizing walk up and say my name
to me before I can even open my mouth
Chieko what's up with you man it's no
amount of money that can buy that that
view is what it's about
so it's like once you figure those
things out and once you start to put
forth for effort then that's what the
universe would give you if you're really
genuine and like I said in my opinion I
really believe if you're not hurting
yourself knowingly or hurting anybody
else normally everything that you do is
going on at you some type of result yeah
I'm at a point now my career where it's
the money is becoming a little bit more
of like a factor and maybe a motivator
just for the sheer fact of just wanting
to start reinvesting it into everything
I'm doing to start doing what I'm doing
but just at a higher let me ask you this
question do you come from money no no no
no podunk like I look purebred but I'm
inbred okay yeah yeah oh really so you
from originally Summerville Georgia some
of your George example some villainville
Zambia some vo somewhere yes some
village or parents educators like I come
from like like a connected and strong
background in terms of a service
background you know but yeah I don't
come from money or anything like that
but see even that like one thing about
financial status is that you know most
of us and when I say us I mean black
people have never had anything mm-hmm
so it's one thing to get some money but
what you're gonna do with it when you
get it cuz getting it is a whole lot
easier than keeping it hmm yeah I mean
to get it you can get some money about
how you gonna keep it and that's a whole
nother journey that you have to take to
learn something that you've never had
before it's like if I you know if you
look at it like this
and for some reason people don't
acquitted and their minds like this but
I do but if I walk into a judo class
today I'm gonna get the [ __ ] beat out of
me I'm gonna get tossed around and beat
up because I don't know what to do I
have to learn what to do
money is the same way if you walk into
some money today you're probably gonna
get tossed around and get the [ __ ] beat
out you because everything that you
think works you have no idea you just
assuming that it works because you never
had nothing and you feel like all I
needed some money and that's gonna fix
everything that's going on with me and
it'll fix a lot until you realize that
what you need to be fixed can't be paid
for you know I mean so it's like I'm for
financial stability just because I like
to have the moon bounce I like to have
that ability to be able to eliminate
stress for my loved ones and I have the
problem of worrying about man this
happened or this happened that's the
beauty of financial stability to me the
beauty of having some money is being
able to you know something happens and
you know like [ __ ] toilet breaks or
your sink breaks down oh it's gonna be a
thousand dollars cool that just that
right exactly that's the beauty of
having money to me other than that
everything else is something that's way
bigger than any dollar amount can ever
give you that's what a real work comes
in to get those things to be in a place
where you could be on a bus in Australia
like I was I had people walk up to you
and on a metro bus in Australia which I
probably had no [ __ ] business being
on anyway but I'm just do feel Ike that
walk up and show you a video and they
phone at him watching you do the work
that you do and I'm in Australia being
paid to be there to shoot a pilot for a
show that never came out so does that
mean that I'm not successful because it
never came out Oh am i successful
because I got the opportunity to go to
the other side of the world and work and
get paid for it
it's all perspective it's all how you
look at it when you're scrapping
together how important is saving verse
reinvesting
and like what you're doing you got to
invest in yourself you got to spend
money on you know whatever it is you do
but it's levels to that there's
different elements to that like I have
been a person who has been in the
fashion my whole life just because I
grew up in the house with a lot of
people who will fly and that's just
something that that I picked up on and
that's an investment and to me because
I'm gonna perform clean and neat that's
my auntie used to tell me you can
accomplish anything in this world as
long as long as you clean and neat as
long as when somebody sees you they look
like you you can start a conversation
with anyone and if what you have won and
what you look like is natural for you
like I just got on a you know black
sweat top and some black shorts but it's
genuine I'm comfortable so when I walk
up and shake your hand you're not
looking at me as a threat because my
energy matches it's clean and neat and
so you can establish whatever you want
to establish based on that now that's an
investment into what I do but whatever
it is you got going on you know you got
your own camera your own right
microphones you know I mean all of that
is an investment into yourself and
saving is it's important but everybody
always say you should save for a rainy
day and you know the rainy days and
that's cool
but what are you gonna do if you got the
money in the rain comes and it doesn't
help gonna lose it all cuz you're gonna
think you got to spend it must not be
spending enough or I must not be saving
enough to feel comfortable you can't
have you can't put your in my opinion
you can't put your your your interest in
just having financial success because
it's important as financial success is
especially in America you got to have
some type of peace of mind to go with
that so you know save some money in
order to invest in yourself but once you
invest in yourself then you know you'll
stop thinking about it
like the thing that I think
getting into certain circles does it let
you realize that the conversation is no
longer about money when I was broke all
we talked about was getting some money
now that I'm not broke anymore we really
have conversations amongst the people
that I'm around about money because it's
not even anything to talk about but it
takes you to get something to learn that
I'm not saying you know listen to this
and just think that I'm saying you don't
need money you need some money I hope
you get some so you can learn how to use
that within yourself but once you start
to make it for real and make some money
then you realize that it's really not
something that people discuss when they
don't have to so the quicker you get out
of letting that be the motivating factor
for whatever it is you do then the
quicker you'll see that you know it's
gonna come to you and you've been around
I mean you know Diddy like Steve Harvey
and all like the 1% of 1% right on this
planet the high end of the high end yo
so it's like what it what have you
learned you've seen you've seen that
worlds like what have you learned being
in that environment that maybe you could
share with listeners I'm a big energy
person I believe me I'm not a religious
person you know I mean I don't I don't
you know believe and I believe I believe
there's a god but I don't believe in the
religious aspects believe in the glow I
believe yes right now that's my favorite
movie last drag and I got a pain in the
Bruce Leroy hanging over my bed but the
glow and that's another person that I
would love to meet Barry Gordy because
just to shake his hand and thank him for
giving the game that he gave in that
movie but I believe in energy kind of
let's just use as an example to glow
like the point of that movie was to let
you know that it's already in you you
are the master you already been the
master but you just had if the whole
movie was him figuring out who he was
and the journey that he had to go
through to get that and at the end of
the movie when sho'nuff was beating the
[ __ ] out of him and putting his head in
the water and he lifts him up and said
who's the master and he looked at him
and said I am he went through all of the
different lessons that he had learned to
get to the point of having a glow but
the glow to me is just
what projects out of you and the more
you become accepting of the fact that
you got it the bigger it gets no so for
me what I learned the most about being
around guys like Diddy and Steve Harvey
and Nick Cannon and all these different
cyber people is that I have the type of
glow that is comparable to those guys my
energy fits into a space with Giants
live you know I mean and I'm not there
in regards to the status aspect of it
but my energy is enough to fit into a
space where all of this exists so it's
like that's what I felt about walking
into a room and seeing somebody who it's
like whoa you know I mean and on the
video if you watch it did he walked up
to me and was like Chico what's going on
man you changed your diet
I was like whoa not only does this
[ __ ] know me he know me well
enough to know what I used to look like
yeah you know that right there is that's
the energy to me it's just being able to
know that because we all got big balls
of energy that's in front of us and you
ever you ever walk into a room and
somebody come it's like it's two type of
people it's people that walk into a room
and change the energy and there's people
who walk out of a room and change the
energy mm-hmm so you can be one of the
two people you can be one of the people
who walk into a room and the room
brightens up or you're gonna be one of
the people who leave out of the room and
it brightens up so to know that I'm one
of the people who walk into a room and
brighten it up is one thing but to walk
into a room with with giants and they
still smile when they see you and say
what something when they see you that
means that you got I got the type of
energy that I need to keep curating and
feeding that to get to a point where
they are because that's what they did in
my opinion I mean so that's really what
I learned the most about being able to
be in these spaces that me and the
people that I'm surrounded by
we have a unique type of in a special
type of energy man and the energy that
we project is so big at this point that
you can share the room with people who
will live forever you know I mean that's
that's what is so mind-blowing about
this 85 South
I don't recall - oh it's like a movement
it's like a revolution like the impact
that 85 South is making not just on the
comedy game but like entertainment it's
like unfounded what you guys are
achieving and I've talked to Chad the
producer and Carlos and Clayton were
like what is your take on 85 South and
why it is having the impact that it has
one because it's genuine this is a
genuine relationship that we have like
fly came in what two seasons after we
came in but he fit right in and and just
when we communicated with each other it
was just always genuine so that's the
basis of it okay but one of the major
things that I think it is I mean a hotel
lobby right now we are know this is a
mud this is the come up this is the
hotel just and they excited you know you
guys went from like the studios the trap
yeah and that's the thing like the only
way that that can happen is just if it's
genuine you have to be excited about
going to do whatever it is you're going
to do and one of the major things I
think that makes what we do a little
different is that we all hold our own in
our own right I got shows in Atlanta
this weekend DC was in Pittsburgh last
week I mean just yesterday Carlos is in
Cincinnati Ohio headlining a funny bone
all weekend so we all do what we do
individually but we come together and
get on stage together you know kings of
comedy is a legendary movie because you
imagine if we got to sort you got to CDL
you know I mean say it Bernie and Steve
come out together and talk [ __ ] together
that's a whole nother movie right you
know so I think that's really what gives
people the different feel you've never
seen it done
that way before and it's all improv they
should be magic to us too like we don't
practice anything we get on stage and we
go you know I mean we got my man Craig
right here I'm gonna attest to that we
never sit around and have no meetings
about I Pro we in this city so that's
what we don't none of that because it's
so genuine and like I said that energy
that I was talking about it's so strong
and it's so genuine that when we get on
stage it's literally magic so I think
that most people can see that and even
the people who may have negative
opinions about what we do because you
know you see all of that it doesn't that
doesn't matter you know I mean because
that is the same type of effect that the
positive energy has even though you
don't like it it's affected you some
type of way and what it is that we do
has made you feel real emotion so that
means it's something special I heard
somebody say there Martin one funny the
other day I looked at him like they was
crazy but he was able to sit and have a
conversation to me as to why he didn't
which means you watched it long enough
to develop the opinion that you had so
it really doesn't change in regards to
the what I'm giving you or what what
Martin did in regards to giving you that
show he gave it to you and because he
gave it to you he was able to formulate
something that lasted for long after he
stopped doing it and still have people
having conversations about it right now
and that's the type of energy that we
create with the 85 like god forbid if we
was to stop tomorrow the things that
we've done up until this point I feel
like would be talked about for a long
time because people haven't even really
grasped the reality of it like to go
back and watch like these guys that
really doing something completely
different so I just think that the
reason why we're able to you know do
what we do not necessarily the success
because that just came organically but
the reason why we're able to do what we
do is because it was just based in a
genuine he's we brothers for real you
know I mean we don't sit around and talk
about work we talk about life you know I
mean we know each other's children fam
I've been to these people's house and
hugged their mothers you know I mean
like all of us you know it's just a
different type of environment and for us
to be able to have that type of
Brotherhood and still be able to get on
stage and share the light it's amazing
man and the eighty five percenters
definitely reflect that yeah they they
serious you know I mean and in there
it's in this it's it's crazy to me
because you know all around is just a
blessing man it's just a super blessing
because like I said like we've been
talking about this whole time my
perspective is different in the losest
perspective is different lies
perspective is different so a lot of the
things that will probably cause
dissension or cause disruption amongst
this process just doesn't affect us the
same way I've seen people you know we
work in all different types of
environments I've seen how opinions
affect people I've seen people really
look at comments that people leave and
be truly like deflated right there's no
way I can be deflated about anybody's
opinion you are entitled to your opinion
but I'm entitled not to give a [ __ ]
about you know I mean and that's whether
it be whatever it may be but none of us
allow what they say quote unquote to
affect what we do you know I'm saying
I'm gonna be me regardless of whether or
not you like it or not you don't have to
like it but until you decide to get up
and do something that's gonna stop me
from doing what I do you gonna have to
just keep not liking it but I've seen
the people that do like it you guys are
like the Beatles out there yeah I mean
no it's that's the baby or anything the
people who do love it like that's
something no I'd like to look at life in
the regards to this you don't have to
know what you want you just have to know
what you don't want hmm and don't like
so as long as you knows you don't like
you're good the love the only matter
like that goes without saying because
that isn't what somebody's gonna need
motivation on so I don't even like to
really discussed those type of things
because you don't need no motivation on
how to deal with love but the negative
stuff and they hate that comedians and
entertainers get is what I see deflate
them so I can offer any type of
perspective it'll be based on that
because the love is the love you don't
need no preparation for love
love is love and whenever you get it she
won't know it's love I had a dude in the
mall walk up on me man
literally she go oh you knew I
appreciate you bro I'm walking away with
an eight and it's like you don't have to
prepare for that no I mean that doesn't
take any preparation because you're able
to receive that however you receive it
but it's the other stuff that you have
to prepare yourself for the stuff that
you don't want so once you prepare
yourself for the stuff that you don't
want everything that you want just
becomes that much more magnified because
the things you don't want don't affect
your ability to recognize the things
that you do mm-hmm and the the come up
as will land this plane here is one
thing that helps convenes keep
perspective is like bombing on stage and
I asked every comedian on here like a
story of getting booed or like just an
unforgettable show they were just
everything went wrong right like do you
have one top of mine and this is how
crazy it happens for me okay it's not
unique I am as a human being my first
show I used to do to open mic night at
the Greensboro comedies on every first
and second Thursday of the month right
so I went the first thirst because I
never been to a comedy club before this
point like I didn't grow up thinking I
would be a comedian that was not at all
it wasn't my in my goals until I started
you're gonna be a cameraman right no I
was gonna be a news anchor news anchor
hey yeah when I was in college I thought
I was gonna be a news anchor when I was
young I thought I was just gonna be rich
dope Dylan Street [ __ ] okay that was it
I thought that was what you wanted to do
until my uncle got murdered and I was
like oh yeah this ain't it cuz he was a
hundred times tougher than I can ever be
and I knew that and I said well if
that's what his fate was oh I know what
they got for me
I had to do that cuz I was trained by
these people so I know the reality of
being out there in that environment is
you know you hear people say it all the
time you're gonna death for jail but the
reality is death or jail like when you
see death in jail right next to you it
has a different type of feeling than it
does when people just saying it to you
because if you're never experienced that
you don't know what it felt like to have
to view a body or to have to you know
smell a person clothes that's gone
forever you know I mean those little
nuances that people don't recognize but
once I got on stage at the second open
mic night was the second week after I
went to the first show four minutes
killed in my mind which I know now been
in the game you can't really kill in
four minutes but in that four minutes I
smash so at that point I'm in it the
very next open mic night the month after
which is September I went up with the
confidence of Richard Pryor Chappelle
[ __ ] I'm talking about it was you
couldn't tell me that I wasn't do Bernie
Harvey I'm telling I was everybody I got
on a stage and a me I'm come out it was
me and for some reason wasn't it was
probably like I say 40 50 people at the
first open mic that did this one was
packed all white people and I got on
stage talking some [ __ ] and they was
just like and this is the thing booing
is different because boring means you've
affected the people some type of attacks
that means you invoke some type of
emotion to where boo [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
but when that silence that means that
they don't have a clue how to feel about
what you're doing up there and that
silence is nasty it's two types of
silences in comedy that I've learned at
least in my experience is the silence of
say next that quiet that comes over the
room so they can hear everything that
you're saying and then it's that quiet
of who's next what's next and who's next
I was in the who's next I mean they just
was like
and that was one of the biggest lessons
that I've ever learned but luckily for
me that wasn't the first time that that
happened to me I'm in the fraternity so
I remember me and my fraternity went to
Indianapolis to step in the Circle City
Classic and we had this thing where we
was like old man we had these goofy wigs
and suspenders and all that and this was
a step show in arena you're like it was
an arena and I'm talking about
we got no love it was so bad that the
people who came from our school was
scared to even clap cuz they don't want
nobody to know we was with you
so it humbled me once I got off stage
that time like no this ain't the thing
that's just going you got the work
problem that the work you got to really
work and from that moment on I've worked
and luckily in that work I already had
to establish if I don't care about what
nobody thinks about give a [ __ ] what you
think you know you can think whatever
you want to think about me so on you god
bless you but I'm gonna work and even if
you don't appreciate what I do or don't
like what I do you're gonna have to
respect the fact that he doing it and
that's the part that has always kept me
in my own pocket you know I mean being
able to be comfortable onstage and being
honest onstage because I don't care
about what you think about the things
that I love you know I mean I know the
people who love me unconditionally
and I make sure that I do everything in
my power to make sure that it stays that
way everybody else is just somebody who
is formulating an opinion based off what
I do and you were entitled to that and
I'm gonna continue to do what I do and
you can continue to formulate the
opinions that you choose to formulate
around it but I'm gonna work work it's
what it's about man we made it this is
what this is what it's about right here
like how how unique is it to be drinking
some hot breath water negative I it
tastes like slob it's pontus water this
is very good Georgia Georgia mountain
spring water Georgia mountains on
Mountain spring water listen you got to
be from some veal to be able to find
your own spring so I'm saying got it
listen great we got enough white people
man we got a gives of white people
he's the plug he got a spring most
[ __ ] got hookups on you know [ __ ]
rims and [ __ ] like that
you got a hookup on a spring hey man
come on down to some field we got a
spring that you can go down there and
bother you some water up I got water and
whites so whatever y'all need that's
what they a man we wish you might
appreciate this is cool man I appreciate
you for having me over here I appreciate
you being on here man and we've been
we've been chipping away at the 85 South
gang we've just got DC left oh yeah
that's gonna be a good one man you know
that's gonna be good like that's
definitely gonna be a good one man you
know but this is these type of
conversations are necessary and you know
if I can be any motivation to anyone
who's out here trying to pursue this as
a career pursue this as a dream my
biggest advice would be block out the
[ __ ] man whatever you consider the
[ __ ] to be block it out figure out
how you can block it out and then once
you block it out start walking and keep
on walking well I mean based on our
conversation would you mind looking into
the camera and tell people who you are
and why they should listen to hot breath
podcast my name is Chieko bean and the
reason why you should listen to hot
breath podcast is because this
[ __ ] got his own water all right
remember how Prince I came had his own
money he got his own water and he
dressed like a real estate lawyer not a
real estate agent he's a real estate
lawyer cuz he both you know you can call
him to get a house and if your back got
broken a car accident that's why you
should watch high breath podcast because
it's unique this dude doesn't fit any
mold of what somebody supposed to look
like which is the reason why he can
bring you all different type of content
because you know he's not setting any
type of way he's setting work and that's
what it's about so make sure you support
him dammit breath hot breath water I
don't make your breath hat because it's
from a natural spring in some veal and
only he can get to
so that that's it hot breath averse
you've heard it from the man himself
Chico bean if you enjoyed this hot
breath Assad reach out to him directly
on social media let him know how helpful
this episode was at the end of the day
determine what success is to you and
then start yep put in the work so we
appreciate your support iron hot breath
if you love us if you like us you want
to support us hot breath podcast calm is
the website all social media hot breath
pod Joe buyers comedy calm long story
short we're on YouTube as well if you
want to see this man live and in living
color but this is a milestone in this
show for sure I don't they have no doubt
thank you so much for being on your
Chico
[Music]
I breath